[Music]
and that told me some news submitted by
thumb wars champ hmm a Christian family
refuses to pay income taxes because it
goes against God's will you gotta try
you gotta try I'm Christian to shoot
your shot yeah that's kind of cool this
is some Wesley Snipes [ __ ] I love it all
right that man is my hero taxes and he
said show me the law that says I have to
pay taxes make the religious yeah and he
was in jail the guy's a [ __ ] legend
dude that's pretty gangster he's like I
haven't heard [ __ ] about having to pay
taxes he's like I think it's a [ __ ]
hoax
well Paul because it doesn't see where
the [ __ ] goes so it's like this [ __ ]
ain't real they wouldn't [ __ ] me over
like this and they did there's a huge
debate about is it constitutional or not
oh yes to pain come on now like is it
American to pay taxes because that's one
of the main things that the founding
fathers they didn't want I mean that's
what the whole Boston Tea Party was
about right so it's like why are we
doing what we ran away did it start it
was about taxation without
representation the idea is is that we
can pay our taxes but we're being
represented involved and that's and that
Boston Tea Party their life we're not
being urine represented but we're tech
paying taxes [ __ ] you guys and income
ties the guy part I miss they put it in
like a 1940 or something 1950 in context
yeah it was like 1915 or some [ __ ] I
think it's the IRS or no they pay taxes
I think it's the IR the income tax of
Tonga is a new thing Oh what's the
difference we turn income tax and tax
like there's federal tax sales tax
there's all different taxes they don't
actually take it out of your 1930 and
that's income tax mm-hmm some states
don't have it was briefly amazing 90s
but then in 1913 Oh 8 1930 but it wasn't
like I found that sales tax it Texas is
the 30th home sales taxes was in the
thirties but income tax was income tax
was 1913 good job Steve fun enough I
guess thank you fortune why do see the
necessity of taxes pounds I just don't
like to pay
I don't like to pay either I don't think
anyone does I don't mind paying it if um
or it's going look if I get a receipt or
if they're like the this part line here
this but then I'm like cool that makes
them if you could choose that be kind
but then why don't we all just be like
roads yeah yeah we don't want I think
we'd all be like drones in Afghanistan
Yeah right with me look old government
like government workers are like the
president or whatever it is they are
they're all getting paid so much of our
taxpayers money and then like we barely
see any of it in like the streets and
[ __ ] like the you know the especially in
like very liberal states have you
noticed do bars are maybe cuz it's just
major cities are liberal and they're
just hard to maintain but there's a lot
of money that goes in but we just don't
they should take a month and pay
everyone like what you would get your
full paycheck not no have no payroll
taxes for one month just so everyone
feels what that would be can you do that
I feel like my sister has a regular
nine-to-five job and I think it's called
going minute cent or something that
we're all thin yeah what is that soybean
yep yeah where you can like get your
whole paycheck but then at the end like
you don't have to pay like us you know
like a 1099 so that's what I'm saying I
wish that we would do that and just let
everyone keep their money for one month
so they could see what it how that feels
cuz I don't think a lot of people know
how much money they're missing I feel
like we get the feeling but then at the
end of the year we're like [ __ ] well
that's a lot of money you know
alright this story here is that a pair
of Christian mission alright in our
stress in Australia they were recently
ordered to pay over two million
Australian dollars through the
Australian Taxation Office because they
were not paying their income tax did
they have a non-profit no so they're
saying that no like they should have
been paying but they're arguing that the
taxation law is in contrary to the law
of the Almighty God
Oh Lord what did the Almighty God say
just tithe
no he's saying that bow shot must tithe
10% of your thy income that's lesson
pretty waxes
oh yeah that's way tight what's up
they're saying that they sow their
siblings by the way they're arguing that
the law of all-mighty siblings and
married well they're really close to
Paris I was imagining Australian version
of down oh so then there was a that the
law of Almighty God was supreme in
Australia and they didn't know anything
to the Commonwealth because they
belonged to God so are they giving 100%
to God two million how much money they
make a lot
oh it's cuz they weren't paying for
several years how many how many though
still yeah cuz I could be much I could
be ten years well I think with all the
fees like the late fees well that may be
like Jesus late fees accrues two million
dollars do they own a business or
something yes okay that makes sense
because income tax their to take the
money from you before you get your
paycheck yeah like payroll does that
right and then but if you own your own
business you have to report and pay on
your own well I wonder what kind of a
store was it like a like a Jesus
bookstore Church maybe a church oh do
the churches have to give tax not in
America exempt a lot of people think
that that's horseshit
it's nonprofit we should start a church
yep you know what people do boss
trillion has the marsupial texts that's
what l ron hubbard did that's a Gleeks
pathology he was like [ __ ] his tax
y'all found a hunk of a farm and it work
yeah it was all for his sci-fi books
right and he didn't want to pay taxes on
those so he just made it a religion but
he actually turned it into a real call
to you the Church of JK if you could
just build one sick Church you're pretty
much in the clear dude that's true
that's what he did he built one sectors
and then it all sort of branched out
from there that's the one I think you
start with a boat is that the one off
the 101 I don't know if that's the first
one I don't know
damn dude I want to do that nobody finds
pretty [ __ ] so what kind of business
they own but in the photos I was given
they did on a business somehow that was
like well I guess it doesn't matter baby
there's rumors going around that Connie
was starting her Sunday service because
so he doesn't have to pay
to solve everything he made which would
be brilliant I saw it at Coachella and
it was awesome to be there you know but
it's even more this only Warwick or is
it no you just serve it Coachella was
only music but it is probably service if
the government didn't miss manage money
and there weren't all these stories of
them [ __ ] up with our tax dollars I'd
feel much more confident with paying
taxes it's not that I don't pay taxes I
have to pay them but I feel like I'm
paying unwillingly instead of paying
like [ __ ] yeah I'm giving to my
government and we're doing some rich
[Music]
they write the loopholes bro so they
don't have to pay yeah and what our idea
of rich is isn't really rich we just
can't fathom the level of what real
riches so and we blame people that we
think are rich so they're not really
really not the rich people you're like
just upper middle class and bulbs mom so
when we see people that like you know
driving a nice car and all that well I
look at these [ __ ] rich people
they're exploiting us and whatever but
in reality they're also being exploited
to the real-deal [ __ ] is like what's up
my name is Jeff Bezos I have Amazon
hello comm hi you're a politician right
yeah cool I'm gonna fund your [ __ ] okay
hey I need you to knock it off with all
these [ __ ] tad you got in for my
business thank you got it well no no a
lot of the corporate tax rates get sent
at percentages that hurt small business
yeah that's what Joseph are you and a
lot of normal voters they're just
thinking like if you have a CEO in front
of your title they think you're rich
yeah but the real rich are like big like
fortune 500 CEO so for and there are the
people who are like paying zero percent
taxes and [ __ ] if you if you okay so
let's say there's a Salesman right and
he makes two million a year do you
consider him rich I would right most
people would most people would but
actually he's probably one of the most
[ __ ] person in the world because he
doesn't own as a phone business he's a
Salesman which means he'll poly and he
passed his tax bracket so he's
considered rich but imagine making two
million dollars and you worked your ass
off right
it takes a million from you every year
50% and you're not mission yeah and it's
not fair because that's when people get
into like but people like to think that
back in the 1940s when we were in the
middle of war or two that because the
the top percent of the tax rate I think
was like [ __ ] eighty five percent or
more and so back then people like people
like to say that well we were getting
taxed like crazy back then but incomes
were we're grading the economy did
really well but that's because like you
said people were doing shady [ __ ] they
were charging cocktail lunches and [ __ ]
as tax write-offs and they were they
were cutting corners it's not that they
were actually paying eighty five percent
if you actually look at what they
actually paid in taxes yeah similar to
now it's like forty five fifty percent
[Music]
okay okay that was like God said we
don't need to what is it hats oh you can
tell huh yes I love people that like
just say God told me this and it's sighs
that's it so they said that they told
the judge
well God filled until 2011 both he and
his sister had paid taxes but as their
spiritual relationship deepened that
they realized that by continuing to pay
taxes it would be going against God's
will so then the opposing side argued
that the Commonwealth was under God's
jurisdiction which meant that by abiding
by the laws of men it would cure a wrath
to his almighty so that's the function I
love how they they make this statement
as if people are gonna be like Oh God
told you why don't you just say so in
the beginning what the [ __ ] dude
I didn't know you had God on your side
my bad financially like what's his phone
number
oh honey how's he doing I know so then
the court argued well if you can't find
a passage in scripture or gospel that
says thou shalt not pay tax
okay and they even entertain that yeah
then you gotta pay your monthly they're
being cheeky cuz I already know I wish
the Bible survived
we need a new King James near New King
James they are ordered to pay an
estimated one point one five nine
million Australian dollars and then the
other person one point one six six
million that's a lot it was covering
their income tax debt penalties
administrative costs and running balance
account deficit debt this is like I'm
watching a movie we're about criminals
and I want them to get away with it but
the men didn't yeah you wanted them to
well I just do it all I think in all
movies I want the criminals to get away
with it if I'm following the criminals
and this kind of feels like that because
they're the protagonist of the story
yeah because I don't know the other side
of the story I just hear their argument
so I'm like oh I hope they get away with
it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]